[Music]
i hear you have a taxidermy collection
that fascinates me i want to hear about
that i i have a taxidermy horse so you
stalked a member of a boy band and you
have a taxidermy collection i think we
know where jc is now by the way
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
although it would kind of be cool if you
could
[Laughter]
you will one day we're in california
everything's legal here eventually
you're right people can smoke pot on
their unicycles it's all fine let's just
hope the big people hear you so what
what do you uh what kind of
taxidermy i have of course
have a taxidermy i have a three-week-old
diet of natural causes miniature horse
and i have um i have a chick who i just
got her name's linda well she's not
alive but her name would have been linda
and then i i have a um an owl named
beatrix
and uh i have a few butterflies
that's about it for now
i'm calling the police
i'm just getting started
since the beginning
we have the cool we have the coolest uh
taxidermy animal of all time that we've
used on our show of all time throughout
the years of all time it's a screeching
raccoon with a jet pack you do not yeah
take a look at this video clip it's the
greatest thing
it just it goes in circles that's all it
does
most most uh live animals can't do that
yeah would you like that
i will give it to you
i will give it to you here on the air
your own taxidermy jetpack raccoon
[Applause]
it's fantastic isn't it great this is um
who did this let's not talk about that
yeah
we're not he snitches
and he died in natural death yeah
obviously yeah can i keep him yes i'm
giving that what do you think this is
and this is for you and cut take it away
would you like me to hold them for you i
assume it's a him yeah you can't be sure
we can go out on the highway and get
another one uh
i can't believe this is my this is mine
yeah that's the kind of show we have him
yeah that's the kind of show we have
what's his name
i don't know his name
he's not well done what do you mean
i mean
you're being critical of the gift i just
gave you
you're right i'm sorry you just said i
love taxidera oh and look what i happen
to have oh thank you
i see a flaw
here right now she's like she's not
wrong yeah
it really it really is it's on a jet
pack marginally a record accidents
my mind is blown yes
i think you are a good actress
this is incredible
[Applause]
[Music]
that's yours that's yours to keep and
now we have uh maybe make a hat out of
them no i'm keeping them away you know
what i love now we have a clip of your
movie that we're gonna throw to and i
don't know how that goes from this
but we're just gonna do it the movie's
called gone anything we need to know
about this clip
stop that
um
you i am threatening the cops which i
would never do in real life but
it calls for it right it's a movie as
it's a thrill oh it's a movie
i didn't even talk about it it's a movie
i thought this was a clip from your real
life
yeah no i don't i i i didn't really set
it up well but it's um it's a it's a fun
movie and uh well fun it's a scary movie
and i had fun doing it and i'm talking
to the cops and you're holding a dead
raccoon
let's take a look at this clip from gone
hey
if my sister dies it's your fault
i bet that's molly right now
hey is molly with you
no why
i'm at the police station so i'll call
you back
she's not with her boyfriend that's
because she might have two of them did
you ever think of that look joe why
don't you just go home you know get some
sleep i'll sleep when he's dead
[Applause]